oh I I think this is a very great
initiative because of course the the the
Nobel Prize that everything that this
related to is one of the great
attractions that Sweden has four people
from all over the world they want to
know because it's very very interesting
III think nobody has explained why the
Nobel Prize has this extraordinary
repercussion all over the world all over
the world which is unique because there
are many wars and international prices
which but no one has reached this
extraordinary respect and curiosity and
interest that the Nobel Prize produces
Oliver Oliver the the world so a museum
in which through very concrete examples
the the importance of the Nobel Prize
can be shown you know to visitors I
think would be extremely rewarding for
for people who are so curious about the
the Nobel Prize and can follow the
reasons why the Nobel prizes have been
considered you know two different people
from different disciplines and it will
be very very very interesting and I'll
come to see it i hope it finished before
I when I am still there you know